ever since I started selling my fake
guru guru course my net worth took a
turn in the happy hockey-stick direction
and I'm not gonna lie to you guys I've
been lying to you but it's time to come
clean and I think you'll see I'm still
the same humble guy I was before but the
truth is I've been using a green screen
for my old set back when I was broke the
whole thing was CGI'd in a multi-million
dollar Hollywood studio to make myself
relatable to you to pretend to be the
ordinary Joe but I'm tired of being
something that I'm not now that I hit a
hundred K subscribers and I am now
seeing your 100 K ever since I sold the
most successful Clickbank product of all
time I wanted to tell you guys the truth
I want to show you a day in the real
life of the real me now my day begins in
my very small summerhouse which some
people call a chateau but I don't really
I think that's a little bit pretentious
but use whatever terminology you like
the point is I wake up every day to
Bartholomew who's brewed me a single sip
of the world's most powerful expresso
which I normally inject with a single
five nanometer needle unfortunately at
the recent Maudie summit which is what
we in the biz call it Bill Gates asked
me to donate all my needles to assist
him in his world domination vaccine or
whatever so I gave them all away so
unfortunately I've had to just drink it
out of a cup like the rest of you so
bottoms up to the proletariat here
next comes the board meeting now I can't
tell you what we talked about because it
is very confidential but let's just say
you could just hang out outside here
good news is you're fired
bad news is you've got all you've got
just one week to regain your job
starting with tonight you can't close
the Leeds you're given you can't close
you are hit the bricks pal and beat it
because you are going out the leads are
weak the leads are weak leads are weak
you're weak I've been in this business
15 years what's your name
you that's my name you know why mister
because you drove a Hyundai to get here
tonight I drove an $80,000 BMW that's my
name
all right I think that was a pretty
successful meeting on today's agenda was
as always how do we deliver more value
to you and I'm happy to say we have
delivered for current consumers of the
fake guru guru course and I'm announcing
it right now never announce it anywhere
else we now have the option to join the
inner circle Lions Club mentorship which
we never used to open up for anyone and
let's just say if you decide to join
you're going to be shocked at how much
value we deliver for the small upsell of
$10,000 an hour and actually I want to
you know we're gonna get on my jet in a
second here but I just want to tell you
guys we're gonna be joined by one of my
students on the plane so let's get on
this jet and we'll start talking to one
of my mentees and you can see how I do
is hello grant can can you hear me can
you hear me grant tell the people what
I've been teaching you lately he does
this sometimes it's it's a Scientology
thing great grant are you okay grant
calm down and do the breathing exercises
we talked about
[Laughter]
[Music]
grant stop laughing it's not funny grant
I'm telling you I talked to it I talked
with you about this in the last minute
or ship lesson you've got to calm down
and take a deep breath sometimes this
this happens to his brain would it gets
over leveraged in a bear market grant
are you okay
[Laughter]
Grint we're gonna hang up with you right
now I'll check in on you later please
get that under control now around this
time I'm starting to get pretty hungry
for dinner and remember I only one meal
a day on a 16-8 scheduled or maintained
peek physical performance now I really
don't eat anything fancy guys they say
keep it simple stupid right so I just
eat it I just need a sirloin steak you
know with a little bit of broccoli and
then I wash it down with the blood of
the innocents and then it's just off to
bed for me I mean I'm just a regular guy
if I can just have a heartfelt moment
with you guys for a second here I just
wanted to thank every one of you who
bought my fake guru course and got me to
where I am today it really means a lot
to me and I want you guys to be all
confident that I have not changed I have
not changed I'm still the same humble
guy that you just saw back in that
disgusting hovel you know before and you
know I may go back to I may go back to
it'd be you know CGI it in because I
know that you guys like to relate to me
and that's what I'm all about but I just
wanted to give you a peek behind you
know the green screen if you will to
show you my real life will something
magical happen at 500,000 subscribers
and a million subscribers will the
webinar go live the mysterious webinar
you know that will actually get you
access to the behind the scenes fake
guru guru course maybe maybe I you know
who am I to say I'm just a humble man I
hope you enjoyed this this peek behind
the curtains and you know thanks for
getting me here see you in the next one
and don't forget to smash like and
subscribe thank you
[Laughter]